Gary Cohen announcing he's leaving the
White House possibly leaving the West
Wing in about three weeks time he put
out a statement a bit earlier today here
isn't part of what it read he's been an
honor to serve my country and enact
pro-growth economic policies to benefit
the American people in particular the
passage of historic tax reform I'm
grateful to the president for giving me
this opportunity and wish him in the
administration great success in the
future on the heels of that we have a
statement from the president as well
that reads the following gary has been
my chief economic adviser and did a
superb job in driving our agenda helping
the deliver historic tax cuts and
reforms and unleashing the American
economy once again he is a rare talent
and I thank him for his dedicated
service to the American people all that
news breaking just about one hour ago
let's bring in our panel Michael Needham
chief executive officer at Heritage
American heritage action for America Amy
Walter national editor of quote the cook
Political Report and Eli Lake columnist
for Bloomberg View or well good evening
we had a different topic prepared for
you but this is the topic of the hour
let's say Michael your reaction it's
interesting I mean it's something that's
been talked about as potentially
happening for you know many many months
yet it was still surprising what had
happened today Gary Cohn has been some
he's assembled a fantastic team inside
the White House they've had tremendous
accomplishments on behalf of the
president you look at the tax cut which
was historic the regulatory rollback
today the Senate is moving forward with
the rollback of dodd-frank getting at
that bill which attacks America's equity
markets and so Gary Cohen has been there
at the president's side with a
remarkable record of economic success
it's important for the President to
continue doing that and not roll that
back with things like tariffs or some of
the other policies that we've seen
talked about in recent days I believe
they had a good relationship it's it
appeared to be that way but he drew the
line on tariffs ami lirik owned it yes
he seemed to draw the line on a number
of things he was upset about the pulling
out of Paris the courts initially he was
not a big fan of that and then of course
there was a very dramatic break with the
president on the president's reaction to
the violence in Charlottesville with
Cohen saying out loud I was thinking
about resigning I'd actually penned a
letter of resignation
but I'm gonna stick with this
administration but I disagree with the
way that the president reacted to it
saying there's violence on both sides
and that now obviously we've known for a
long time that the tariff issue was one
that divided the president's economic
team he's been on the side of arguing
against more tariffs or any tariffs at
all
so that's not particularly surprising to
see that he's on the other side of it I
agree that it's surprising that it was
today but I think we all sort of knew
that whoever won the war on tariffs was
ultimately gonna stay in and who lost
was ultimately it appeared that Gary
Cohen came from let's say the left side
of the aisle when it came to politics
but Gary cone is citing the Republicans
on the hill on this whole tariff issue
and that's driving this wedge now
between Republicans in Congress and the
president who says I ran on this and
they expect me to do this the president
ran a lot of things that he didn't do it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's a
good thing that we're going to be
apparently embracing an economic policy
from a hundred years ago which i think
is going to be bad for the constituency
that Trump claims to represent this
forgotten man a lot of their prices are
going to go up and you know Gary Cohn
comes from goldman sachs that is
something that is you know in some ways
both left and right and neither left nor
right and it represents the center of
American politics this is a significant
blow and in some ways I think it does
show a kind of fracture of American
politics in a deep way and the fact that
so many Republicans in Congress and a
lot of Democrats too in Congress are
really uncomfortable with the tariff
policy and we'll see how far you can go
but the president has a lot of authority
the West Wing itself and if you look
back over the last 13 and a half months
let's say just on screen we'll put the
numbers and the faces and the names of
those we're in the West Wing are now
gone I count 19 either resigning or
fired 19 in less than 14 months this
tweet from the president on white house
chaos I think is interesting too it
reads the following the new fake news
narrative is that there is chaos in the
White House wrong people always come and
go and I went strong dialog before
making a final decision I still have
some people that I want
always seeking perfection there is no
chaos only great energy Michael well it
certainly feels pretty chaotic today I
mean I think if you look over the last
14 months it's been a white house that
has stormed and then it's come together
and normed and that it's stormed again
and normed again obviously it works
better when when the team is working
together and frankly Washington needs
strong executive leadership Congress 535
people all of whom have different
ambitions and different things that the
word but needs an executive branch that
is sitting there saying this is what the
team is doing let's go forward the chaos
doesn't help with that but we've seen
this in the past and I'm sure that the
White House will come back together and
start operating in a more normal fashion
she said today is that people leave I
got plenty of people who come right
through the door and he said we've have
plenty of talented people who want to
work here at the White House Amy well
we're gonna see who takes the place of
the national economic adviser but look I
think that the chaos is part of the
strategy it's not a bug in the system it
is the system this is where the
president feels the most comfortable
being in a situation where it looks as
if there is no order and he seems to be
the most comfortable net but a lot of
people that is not how they like to work
and it is also a very difficult way to
push strategy all Republicans on the
hill want to talk about right now tax
cuts in the economy period they don't
want to talk about tariffs they don't
want to have to go off on a lot of these
tangents that the president and the
White House seem to be unable to focus
just on that one strategy quickly on
chaos in the White House is it's not
comparable to any modern president and I
think that the number of resignations
the the fact that it's hard to figure
out what the policy is is its own form
of abdication and should weary us all